philadelphia pennsylvania new york city
new york kippy and uncle hank are coming
home to roost baby october 27th helium
comedy club philly pennsylvania come and
see us and then for the new york comedy
festival we're going to be at gotham
comedy club on november 9th these shows
are gonna sell out get your tickies
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage sure is it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out if they grow
up to be classy yeah or if they're just
a big old piece of trash
i'm your host age foley coming at you on
a beautiful day we're down here at
antoine's basement she's out in the
backyard enjoying the fall weather she's
burning some leaves
which her boyfriend's actually cooking
some ice in the garage
and she said it keeps the the police
dogs off the trail
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he's the ceo of are you
garbage international businessman
influencer he's got a lot a lot he wears
a lot of hats yeah cover up his bald
head okay i have a new new nickname for
you oh god well first you were kevin
ryan kevin james ryan sure then he
became kippy i think now with your
meteoric rise you're behind the scenes
you engineered this whole thing i think
you you're you're a thing now okay
and i'm going with
i ready i'm going with kj
do we like it
this has been fun i gotta get out of
here yeah no give it up for kj everybody
t-bone cut that in post what what's up
everybody happy to be here there will be
no referencing of kj moving forward
as always please make sure you rape if
you subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are true true the [ __ ]
roof baby and then
was there
there was one more thing we had to plug
i want to get some holy water
[Laughter]
is that for the kantes and the yams it's
not pornhub
patreon.com ru garbage the greatest
website in all the land sign up get a
bunch of bonus content we got the golf
outing just went up there the ayg
invitational yes sir a lot of bonus
material on there 70 hours is what i'm
told more than that
that's a weekend
a long one
okay anything else no that's it
gang how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good t-bone
mcmuffin you know toby mcmullen toby
mcmullen what's up dudes what up t-baby
dude i'm stoked this is like when your
teacher rolls in the combination dvd vhs
player in class we got a real laser disc
over here
this kid was hot for about nine months
i'd rather watch two dung beetles
go back and play with the bunsen burner
this one's this thing stinks gang we're
kidding of course because we couldn't be
more excited to have our incredibly and
i mean incredibly special guest back
again with us today he's like a five six
timer he's officially i've been thinking
about it part of the family you are a
cousin
you are officially a cousin of the show
yes no monetary compensation
yeah don't be giving them that we're
working on it he will work on it no no
no slowly but surely he's gonna be shown
up to a lawyer but they said i was a
cousin oh he's got real change the wheel
face doesn't he
gang it's cousin in finance
he's a wacky guy oh
thank you for having me it's a pleasure
and honor and a privilege to be in the
studio with the fam leafy t-bone h foley
and my favorite kj
yeah kj woo
kade kj what's up that's a very kj
jacket that is a cagey jacket
yes kj ryan dude kj sweet kj in the
house we gotta get you in the studio
with that billy eilish
get a mixtape also just want to say you
guys got 70 hours of footage and foley
said that's a weekend there's only 48. i
let it slide because i don't want to be
a stickler but that's like three
weekends no i know that's why that's why
i said a long weekend it was a joke or
being funny
buddy it's great to have you back here
i'm so happy to be back all right thanks
for coming
the lights go on and he gets a weird
vibe to him
with a cigarette
i
it was a joke pre-show and then i
thought
i don't think we're already we're
already flattening each other's tires
i can't wait i don't think it is i'm
gonna need a tow truck by the end of the
episode you're gonna be that guy when
we're older what walking around with the
unlit cigarette you got you got a
nicotine problem i just saw we got
tagged in a lot of people tagged us in a
post years you were smoking in a [ __ ]
airport yeah that's crap it's a federal
offense the airport bathroom
and then puts it on instagram yeah it's
crazy like one of these tick tockers
i had a layover in minneapolis long
flight
didn't have a vape
what are you gonna do can't leave the
airport and come back in because of
security you go to the bathroom you
light a bernie you lay a little toilet
paper on fire mask the smell take it you
puffs take out a security
toilet
[ __ ] jason bourne
put on a tsa guys outfit
a trash can as a distraction yes you go
to the other terminal god damn it bomb
threat you get on the flight first it's
all right i wanted a cigarette so i
posed as an airline pilot flew to miami
yes they
what a fun joke about a thing that
didn't happen sure that's all right
that's that's crazy
it's not even worth talking i mean yeah
that's on you you posted it so i'm
[ __ ] turning state's evidence if it
comes down to me listen you rat the
whole family's [ __ ] rats listen you
big fat rat in your [ __ ] rat all
right foley's a big rat outside the
union yeah
did that for a couple seconds i think i
told you that
it's a good gig at my first holy
communion the guy
showed up as like a fun time because my
family's all was so pro union like we
that the guy had it in his trunk and
that's
to like play with the kids he dressed up
as the rat and started just dancing in
the backyard shut up that's how [ __ ]
there's a rat dancing at your face i
didn't think it was with my uncle jimmy
who wasn't my uncle i didn't know you're
not fully that long
what are you judging him you're smoking
in a luggage compartment
down there with the beagles check that
cold in here
is this pressurized
nah man you gotta do what you gotta do
that's not a good look that's that's a
dumb idea that's up there with with you
guys when you when you steal from the
airports with the candy bars that's even
worse now you don't have to kill it on
the airport no i don't steal from you he
would never get away yeah
they got eyes on you the second you go
to the candy aisle
i'm telling you i got a whole pizza you
steal from the airport you smoke in the
bathroom no that [ __ ] house is going
down you might as well get your kicks
before it goes they will jack you up if
if if a [ __ ] air marshal not an air
marshal they got the tsa guys but then
there's another level guys huh
unfortunately i have i'll talk about
both i'm not talking about that bozo
brigade there's another level of bubbles
and brown dudes with the guns and the
[ __ ] and the ar-15s one of them opens
that [ __ ] stall door and you have a
[ __ ] listen if you're lighting toilet
paper on fire um it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
technical mission impossible baby i'm
bonding there i'm in and out i'm not
sitting around smoking reading a paper
getting a few puffs
maybe make an instagram story
make a couple stories you know
edit it in post
i'm not doing live edits i'm doing an
edits on an airplane i got a switcher
okay it edits itself i'm out toby can
you come to jfk with me toby if i email
you can you go back to me quickly that's
stupid that's trashy stop doing that
yeah buy a vape it's always got to be
something with you
i'm not doing it
doesn't come with a lot of claws
yes
yes santa claus is coming to town
when you get real successful and real
famous you're going to be a problem
no problem now what a problem
baby has some power listen the whole
world's getting fire dance
and you got financed you got five dance
[ __ ]
hey i'm just having fun for a couple of
weeks i'm living my best life yeah you
are i'll give you that you're having a
good time you're very you yes we had a
great time in moon tower we're gonna
spend the whole weekend together in
moonshine
no fights no blow ups just a good old
one
the best [ __ ] weekend in the world we
hanged
hung we
the whole time
that night walking home
we're [ __ ] in the 7-eleven cry and
laugh and some stranger goes wow you
guys really like to have fun oh i forgot
about that
i forgot we were
what happened remember what happened i
said something about gatorade
and we lost it
there's a half-eaten sausage in aisle
seven and we're just [ __ ] crying we
were drunk i was on a sack full of
mushrooms
and just all the enzymes i'm i'm i'm ian
you said something about the gatorade
that they only had low cal gatorade yeah
for
i don't know but you left and me and
foliar in line and there's all these
like toys and finally the fat man died
down and he like got his [ __ ] together
wasn't laughing we had that
oh that sigh and dude i squeezed this
thing and it went like
and we [ __ ] died all over again like
shaking getting changed from the cashier
it was so much that was a hoot that was
we went swimming in the water and hole
walt went down at a water hole bike ride
yes the biker boys is scooting booting
toby's 3d
360 filming it
[ __ ] was fun
[Applause]
you guys are like stocked in them alone
over here jesus christ
talk about the [ __ ] iceman square
what the [ __ ] and that balloon deflated
[ __ ] pippin and pippin over here
we were having a good time i'm not gonna
lie i've read the playbook wrong i know
that was coming to me jesus christ
oh that was a no-look pass to a nola
catch oh yikes
gang this is a family episode
[Laughter]
we have a little bit of company we're
going to be reading your patreon
questions as you know you sign up for
patreon you get a question read on the
year bit of a backlog as kj says
but don't worry
kj's gonna get it done oh also shout out
kj we're going to the menzingers baby
yes we are we're going to see the
bedroomers not wait a group of us are
going yes who's going uh me yes you yes
foley toby and shane torres was but he
can't now cancelled yeah yeah he's he's
out on tour with that burke creature yes
you think it'll just be a family time
what do you mean i'm gonna try to sell
that's a vip thing i'm gonna try to hawk
it out for you are you gonna hawk it
we're to try to make a little bit of
caves i'm going to make a little bit
ian's going to get in on the cash you
got to buy everybody t-shirts yeah get
merch merch we'll all get t-shirts yeah
menzingers t-shirts yes i can't wait i
think they have a flag you could
use just give me the bus
hey who painted your bus
could you do my foley
i got a co-host with a hankering for a
shirt anything for you
oh you didn't tell me kj's gonna be here
kj's everywhere
yeah i know i don't know if they're
they're probably whatever all access you
can get is yeah are we gonna meet the
band yeah i'm sure oh my god
i mean really you're not anymore what
was that are they aware of this do they
do do they know us yeah okay
so i'll be known when i walk in into the
into their green room they'll be smelled
for sure
kj moves quick you thought kippy was
fast that's good i don't want to walk
into a green roof they don't know me i
don't want to be some bozo well you are
going to be a bozo because i now have an
affection for these gentlemen yes yeah
well you're gonna look great because i'm
gonna be crying oh god yeah
i talk about showing up the mutants in
table nine
can we get a picture
can i play drums was there really an
anna
did you really live in philadelphia
i'm cool to them they think i'm cool you
guys can't ruin course you're cool
you're kj
as long as they know yeah of course what
do you mean everybody knows kj's and
when i go to their concerts i wear a
leather jacket like you know is that
true
[Laughter]
they spike my hair and wear leather
jackets well they bring you
kj goes to concert
[Laughter]
will they bring you on stage to do
something with them oh can you get us on
stage to sing
oh my god
it's not karaoke
you guys know any limb biscuit
can you close your third eye blind
[Laughter]
so will they bring you on stage
no why
why would i do on stage jj yeah just
cage it up okay jake everybody
can't just go take the leather jacket
off
i mean
all jokes is i think it goes harry
styles and then you right now well as kj
as far as like guys that wear dresses
[Laughter]
as far as the it guys right now okay
i'll take maybe pattinson because he's
got that batman movie coming out oh have
you ever seen good time yeah he's
incredible on that yeah
was this npr
jesus but you take your mustache out for
a walk for a little bit while we do the
show all right we're broadcasting here
[ __ ] bozo i wish there's any check
button i can push
just send them up to the next floor
hey guys you should have a show called
financed where you move in with people
and see how long they can take you
living there oh wow it's pretty good i
want no free rent
[Laughter]
you'd be breaking up couples kids would
be emancipating themselves yeah
i'm [ __ ] the dead and the man
you guys mind if i squat for a while
can i put a glory hole in the bathroom
is everything in the fridge mine
it just makes things funner
holy [ __ ] we got a hot one folks kids
screw balls
you really are yeah those are an odd set
of keys by the way what's that what's
that
yeah there's there's three forklift keys
how many bobcats do you want i'm a
janitor down at the y what are those for
my bicycle and my apartment what are the
black ones black ones yeah it's like a
honda lawn mower
this is what's that what do you got a
craftsman
john deere this is my kryptonite this is
my uh azos it's uh you have three locks
for your bike no i got an extra one just
in case
and then this is my
front door my door and a key
to my
seattle that i still have from
he's bad with keys he stole the he's had
the bathroom key here at toodies for
five months
six months what was the last key for i
stepped on it with a bad joke uh fro
you yeah
a friend of mine's in seattle and she no
longer lives there but it's a key to her
apartment when i was out in seattle back
in 2017. i just never got it back to her
what's crazy is you carry it around with
you it's crazy that it's not
in the realm it's not out of the realm
of possibility
that one day you'll use that key yes it
is i don't know i can see you a [ __ ]
i'm not a [ __ ] creep i'm a [ __ ]
dude that's got adhd i [ __ ] forget
other things
i'm not a creep i'm a guy who's creepy
i'm not a creep i'm a pervert
there's a difference
i'm dreamed
i'm not insane i'm crazy
look at him yeah all right let's give
you back your key
eight months later also
in classic in fashion he has to come
into a bit he opens up the door and go
hey go say i'm gonna run to the bathroom
i got my own key by the way you probably
held a piston for the last two days yeah
i gotta hold it into a drill this bit's
gonna work
toby offered the key said keys are here
i said don't worry
i got my own
not bad ian well played thank you well
played you're back you're here meanwhile
you cost me 35 of 35 bucks with the
super for a new bathroom cake new
bathroom kiwi how to get well where's
that coming from the the [ __ ]
take care of it jj's got it kj don't pay
for bathroom kids sell that ticket high
cage yeah um all right let's get into a
couple of questions or at least attempt
to these always go off the rail quickly
with me
i love getting off the rail with you off
the rail with finance yes
wow that's not bad that's why i'm kj yes
copyright auntie's llc copyright ian
now we own you he's doing it like he
called shotgun copyright in popcorn
fight that's my show touch black no
trademark
i don't remember that one no were you a
big punch buggy guy i was getting
punched
there's not even a car
[Laughter]
we're in the living room
get off of me mom stop i was a big door
knob guy safety in doorknob you guys
played that safety was that i still
played what was that if you farted was
that a farmer you're gonna say safety
and if you don't someone calls doorknob
and you have to beat the [ __ ] out of you
till you touch a doorknob yeah and to
this day i still fart say safety from
ptsd from when i was younger
now did you play that with uh the
friends you didn't have when you were a
kid
how do you get beat up by an imaginary
person
i ever see fight club
i'm kicking my ass
let's talk about roman roman let's talk
about roman we're talking about
getroman.com backslash garbage is what
we're talking about cause let me ask you
this
broke in the house would you fix it take
care of it so if there's something broke
inside what are you gonna do you gotta
take care of it you gotta take care of
it get to roman.com
backslash garbage yeah with roman you
get a free online evaluation for ongoing
care for ed uh all from the comfort and
privacy of your own home you don't need
anybody in the waiting room no one's
snooping around your business
none of that a u.s licensed healthcare
professional will work with you to find
the best treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it ships to you
uh to you free with two-day shipping the
whole process straight forward discreet
like i said no one's all up in your
business no it's great that they take
the time to find out what's going on
before they just start handing it
they're not just blindly writing pills
you know you got to go figure it out if
if you know you need a solution for your
a.d and a prescription is appropriate
they will take care of it right so go to
getroman.com garbage now you'll get a 15
bucks off your first month it's really
time to take care of your od your ed and
remember get started today and you'll
save 15 on your first order of ed
treatment get roman.com garbage do it
yeah again let's talk about express vpn
best in the biz expressvpn best in the
biz you know talk about snooping around
you don't want people snooping around
seeing what you're doing where you're
going just that the other thing
vpns are important these days and
express offers the best one when you're
online you know what you're searching
what you're looking for
you know you don't want everybody all up
in your business you want to you want to
be a little play it a little close to
the chest nor should they but they do
they find out that they you they take
your information they tell you where
they they sell to advertisers where you
were what you were doing who's this
what's he googling why is he at the
neighbor's house the whole nine yards
with expressvpn uh it doesn't matter who
your internet server provide is isps in
the us can legally sell your information
to ad companies expressvpn is an app
that reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so your isp
can't be seen
the sites that you visit nice does that
make sense to you goddamn right it
doesn't i like the sound of it yeah it's
like hey it's like hey if you got a tail
you know what like the detective movies
you got a tail you're gunning it through
the light lose them yeah lose the tail
johnny lose them that's what expressvpn
does
that's what a lot of these bozos are out
there they're all tails it keeps your
information secure encrypting 100 of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available so here we go baby
to protect your online activity today
with the vpn rated number one by cnip
visit our exclusive link
expressvpn.com garbage and you can get
an extra three months free nice on a one
year package that's expressvpn exp
garbage expressvpn.com garbage to learn
more do it yeah do it protect yourself i
don't know if you've asked you that but
that's a pretty good ian question did
you have an imaginary friend growing up
yes did we talk about this yes how could
we have not i don't know if we did but i
could i bet all of my money wait
absolutely probably probably he probably
still has
reunions with
i had an imaginary i got a dinner with
my imaginary friends from high school
coming up i gotta take this phone call
ian how many people are in this room
right now
i mean the couch is full
i brought my fan club
the couch
i don't know who's in the closet here
tony come on in
yes i had an imaginary friend did we
talk yes it was a deer and yes his name
was venatio
what yes you had a not even a human man
what a loser i love animals you're going
to lose your imagination love me because
i have a kind [ __ ] soul
you had an imaginary dear friend yes was
it part human or just deer just deer he
was a dear friend
oh my god i
hate
i hate him cheers
dude you just got fired did he speak
english
he spoke to me yeah
really venetian now was this an actual
deer that existed and you bonded or you
just made up a deer
we bonded but i'm saying there was a
deer that lived like well you're right
maybe my family would go camping and i'd
always like find like little like
there's a picture of i found like a
little chipmunk in a hole and i put a
bunch of rocks along under glass
really that's career crazy dude i put a
bunch of rocks around it and spelled it
out
in a heart and and made i spelled my
name out ian with rocks
and it was my little friend and me and
my parents took a picture what's he up
to now
well we had him in shoot addiction
there was a there's a video of my dad
being like any what's the name of your
friend and i had a little speech
impediment when i was younger and i went
the nation
[Music]
and i really think i was haunted man
yeah wait but you didn't answer was the
deer real and you made up this
relationship
[Laughter]
you had an imaginary friend no no why
that's like a natural part of childhood
yeah for the loonies yeah i was doing my
parents taxes when i was like
[Laughter]
he's [ __ ] blowing up the rat in the
backyard i was on the fast track
kj slid out and the members only jacket
got to work yeah hey what are we doing
let's crunch them numbers hey how much
what's the algorithm looking like guys
freon's in the ac right now huh
you never had an imaginary friend
absolutely not you never i had a i had a
family and brothers i was an only child
okay why are you owning us
cause you know tough luck taking up for
my friends
um it sounds like you're saying fellatio
by the way
which you do enjoy
yeah who doesn't
sure would the deer come into the house
no come on it's an animal do you see
there's a there's a viral video going
around and someone has a zebra in their
house
he's like man these [ __ ] got a
whole zebra and it's just like walking
in the bedroom it's [ __ ] great
zebra i can see you doing something like
that oh yeah how are you doing the other
night with like a rhino the other night
we were in wisconsin and there were deer
like next to the hotel and i was trying
to
walk up to him to see how close they
could get let them run away and then it
tells us
behind me playing the recorder and a
couple of lady killers
literally he's got a recorder yeah he
plays a recorder on stage and and i'm
i'm going let's get closer and then i
edge up a little bit and i just hear i'm
playing the recorder and i look around
it's a tell just playing recorder at me
and a bunch of deer man
you two aren't on a no-fly list
they probably joke at the airport
skulking around the midwest in the
evenings listen man both you dressed in
all black
trash bags for luggage
with a recorder that's the most
unsettling part i know it's honestly i
got a ukulele
[Laughter]
i'm telling you having an imaginary
friend is a very normal thing as a child
and
have i will concede when your imaginary
friend is a deer yes that's the weird
part not the most normal thing but hey
i'm a unique fella sure no i agree yeah
yeah so it wouldn't come into the house
with you and be in your room to be
honest i don't remember i just remember
playing with him in the backyard and
shock therapy
chased away some of the memories yeah
yeah and i remember at one point i told
my family there was uh like a guy in the
living room and he was he was dressed
like uh in armor
i think i saw your poor [ __ ] mother
man i was haunted trying to enjoy your
freaking tv dinner after a long day's
work there's somebody in the living room
oh my god his head's spinning around
all sunday morning cartoons are wrong
my mom's like
put me in like a backpack when she
cleaned the house because if she turned
her back on me i'd be running around
what yeah
not a backpack like a little harness
that attached to the back
it's called a cage
dude that's it's the rim
i picture him on one of those sticks
with the loop that they put on rabid
dogs high energy
they keep you in a distance no my mom
dude my mom would clean the house they
put her and she chained me up on the
yard
put me on a zip line in the backyard you
know i was running around
what were you like with a little piece
of sugar in you when you were a kid i
was only allowed to listen to rap for
one hour a day because i would just run
up and down the stairs
every home movie that we had as a kid
ended with me getting yelled at let me
ask you
every single one
ends with the camera aiming towards the
ground ian no
taking it one step too far yeah
music that would charge you up i don't
know man something about vanilla ice and
mc hammer really got me going let me ask
you this when you picture him as a kid
you picture him with the mustache right
i mean receding hairline
because that's how i when i think of you
as a kid everything's exactly the same
just a smaller body bad case of botulism
were you ever in the hospital for an
extended period of time as a child
absolutely
[Laughter]
it was like my sleepovers
that poor cat you're older
when did that thing die suddenly you
catch the murderer in the act
well it was
you look like you're joking that's
[ __ ] getting out yeah it was taken
away
i'm trying to find the picture of me
with a little heart
in the in the woods but uh what'd you
ask
oh if i ever went to the hospital yes
yeah you never did
no i had an allergic reaction to a
medication
your mom tried to poison you
yeah comet'll do that yeah the
medication was getting my head held
underwater in the bathtub
medication was her driving her car into
a lake
ah i can't believe they didn't kill you
as a kid i'm dead serious i know
i would have thrown you in a duffel bag
and tossed you over a [ __ ] bridge on
the way back from that campsite
you pulled that chipmunk [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here there's someone
in the living room the picture with the
chipmunk is so cute also i used to love
putting on makeup as a kid i'm still
doing me as a clown
oh my god jesus
it looks like you blew a clown
holy [ __ ]
man look at those dead eyes who's the
guy behind you like your father
i thought that was the priest performing
the
exorcism i thought that was a court
appointed
yeah you can see that guy's gunning
badge
you're gonna go away for a little while
you gotta post these pictures up once
was that even halloween why were you
dressed up like that yeah it was
halloween but i also used to not dress
up all right it was christmas
after school after preschool used to
come on and put joker makeup on because
they love batman
yeah most kids that like batman like
batman they don't dress up as the joker
here's here's a video of me being steve
urkel
in second grade if you're in black
[Laughter]
it's cute
are you gonna play for us yeah you know
we're gonna have to post this now
it looks like a horror movie i know
that's found footage yeah
that's real blair witch
here it
oh he's comes back for sure
wait is that your dad yeah he definitely
kicked you over i'm telling you right
now
no he wasn't he was trying to [ __ ]
get rid of it the fix was in
here's here ready just listen just
listen
the video ends
you are [ __ ] you are hall of fame
crazy all the same baby hall of fame all
right stop looking at the
you start crying in a minute all right
couple more
put your phone away
i'm trying to find the uh oh here's a
picture of me in makeup
who's the who's on the left the guy on
the right my cousin
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ]
well you missed the march
i thought she was a puppet
that was one of those porcelain dolls
dude i had the best [ __ ] childhood up
into a certain point not on paper i can
tell you that
all right let's go
did you guys live huh i mean yeah i'm
not i i'd say if i would i'd be an
[ __ ] and ever said i put my mom's
lipstick on yeah there it is i've
dabbled in the rouge department a little
bit
a blast with a nice set of shoulder pads
in it my dad never tried to kick me on a
flight of stairs though i can tell you
that well you know
there was no kick he was trying to stop
the little horse from falling back yeah
i'll i'll find the little picture and
you guys will ooh and all how cute it is
all right we'll do it later let's get
into some questions here come on all
right we got business to do here you
want to see a dick pic no
sorry yours or your girls up
yeah i mean it's just a normal picture
ian but that's the chipmunk his home
oh
the rocks who are these poor people you
rolled up that's just that's my parents
that's your mom that's your mom my mom
pretty tight yeah yeah that's my dad
get your hairline from your dad i see
well you know hey what's the compliment
me too it's a fella yeah i know my mom
you know well what can you do
what do you mean what does that mean
nothing
look at that happy family isn't that
nice i was raised with so much love
and they let me be a little freak
splinter well you see where that guy is
and now here we are
now you're talking about going to the
movies with imaginary friends yeah
freddie did my dear come to the concert
he got jacob
he's a killer in a match pitch
he knows all the lyrics
okay
i can't believe you guys ever had
imaginary friends
yeah no i think we might have talked
about this before well you guys had
siblings yes yeah and cousins and
friends i didn't i was in i had friends
i had cousins but there was a lot of
alone time
it's it's a very only child thing to
have quit laughing at me did your room
lock from the outside of course
had a piece of wood that they pulled
down
they didn't need to i was chained to the
bed were you ever that radiator no i
wasn't they didn't tie you down at night
no
definitely there was some tests done at
some point i would have to assign i
added key to the lock
there were some tests done on you at
some point in your childhood i would
have to assume for adhd yeah
yeah they put they put on iceland's baby
and they're like yeah he's got it
do the mc hammer test
he just
[Laughter]
finance he's ripe with it
i don't know what it is but this kid's
got it
they call it skittles disease
oh god can we get started here what's
wrong with you
i don't know kg
jay kj get it right bozo
oh look at him when i just got glasses
on look at me
oh man
holy [ __ ]
ah there you are yeah yeah i'm back
don't take those off again
it's a family show
he's scaring away the sponsors we're
gonna lose helix
who called you i think it was akash
called you a guess who character
the picture you're peeking out of the
back window of a van
are his eyes both sunken and bulging
he didn't like that
why don't you just worry about your
little buttons back there all right
hey button boy
you're buttons
worry about your buttons that's cutting
i'll stay on the buttons
beautiful
can we conduct some business here
yes yes ruin the fun let's get back to
the [ __ ] business all right well yeah
show us more family vacation photos i
know right you may be right
hey let's review the four pictures you
have as a family
it's in here somewhere and who has that
[ __ ] on their phone like readily like
that me man you guys don't no look at
family photos at home when i'm home
well sometimes you get on with real
people well sometimes you don't have
them in your life
okay okay
i gotta be ready to kill a vibe at any
moment
yeah let's get back to the fun talking
about my sad childhood can we it was a
good fun childhood can we please get
back to the two vacations we took
[Laughter]
where i played with a chipmunk that i
probably killed minutes later
video fireworks
camping two big spenders
never went camping nah never went
camping we should do a camping trip i
would do fun i would i i would i would
go do like one of those like drive and
park once i don't want to i don't want
to hump it out an hour to the woods no
that's fun but the driving park's fun
also get a charter boat go fishing has a
captain show you where the fish are you
get a bunch of rock fish i'm big dude
this is going to be a fun fun summer
yeah okay we haven't made any plans
first of all yes
there's been no plans since november
you're trying to get us to plan to go to
see ghost sources with you and we iced
you on that well first can't you go to
ben's but now
yeah that's right [ __ ] diet you're
ordering bacon from the kosher deli
ayn's come in and had nine pitches so
far i did what are you doing for the new
york comedy festival can i get in on
that what are you guys flying down the
skank fest
you asked me
that question what when you're flying
i'll plan the camping trip okay i'll go
yes
if it ends up being me and you're gonna
be [ __ ]
i'd still rather of course of course
it's velveeta from the fat man i'd still
rather bunk with the deer in that in
that one
hey listen me and the deer are going to
stay in the car he's going to have the
deer he gets a little i want to see the
look on your face when you realize that
deer is real
he's playing in bed smoking next time
it's just some guy with antlers
so where are you from originally
can i bum one of those cigs how do you
know ian
wait can you see me
[Applause]
kj you're on one today boy
man
holy [ __ ] isn't it crazy this is our
this is our job oh i love it gang this
podcast is brought to you by the good
people at better help all right we love
we love this sponsor they're great okay
we're both uh
becoming self-aware of self-care of
taking care of ourselves some more than
others i'm i'm currently in therapy
mm-hmm all right kippy just got a
haircut
uh better help is is a is a top-notch
organization yeah they they assess your
needs and they match you with a licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating under 48 hours they're a
big thing it's not a crisis line it's
not a self-help line it's professional
counseling done security online so
instead of going sitting in the
therapist office like you used to have
to do waiting in the the waiting room
you hear the guy before you crying or
they can hear you cry whatever is going
on
uh you don't have to do it uh you can
log in anytime anywhere send a message
to your counselor it's easy peasy you'll
get a timely and thoughtful response
plus you can sign up for weekly monthly
you know whatever recurring uh you know
it's good stuff whatever recurring date
you need take that step
um
visit betterhealth.com garbage that's
betterhelp h-e-l-p and join over one
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional one more time
special offer for all you garbage
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com garbage do it yes
talking about ladder love ladder turn in
the insurance game
upside down on its head and i respect it
yeah term life insurance something you
really got to look into and the good
people at ladder can help yeah uh before
ladder you'd have to if you wanted to
get life insurance you got to go drive
across town sit in some bozo's office
with a bad toupee he's sweating you got
to talk to him get a sales pitch ton of
paperwork wait six to eight weeks to
find out if you were even approved not
no more now with ladder you get fast
affordable term life insurance without
ever leaving home it's a hundred percent
digital when you apply for three million
dollars or less in coverage no doctors
no doctors no paperwork nothing like
that easy peasy so if you're between the
ages of 20 to 60 you need coverage and
you want to team up with a company
that's redefining life insurance choose
ladder there you go guys do it it's easy
peasy go to ladderlife.com garbage today
to see if you're instantly approved
that's ladder l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage now back
to the show
as much as i don't want to ask this i
want to get to the questions sure i have
to know
you got to give me a little bit more
backstory about the deer was it from
this planet did you have your own
language
it was a it was i loved animals i was an
only child so i had an imaginary friend
it just so happened to be a deer
would it come but it would it go with
you places only at night
no i'd play with them in the backyard
i'd ask for extra food for venetio and
[ __ ] you know little kid [ __ ] wow
ask another guest if they ever had
only um only fans
if they had uh
imaginary friends okay yeah we will
that's going to be i think we i think we
might have talked about it with a couple
of people yeah yeah yeah
i mean there aren't a lot of comics that
were only children an imaginary friend
is is isn't something that's out of the
out of the realm but it's usually a huge
it is it's a deer it's like a guy gary
or but it's it's also like an imaginary
like pet if you don't have a pet i see
what you i see but you picked a deer
well you're not you weren't allowed to
pierce you i love nature what were you
allowed to have pets as a child yeah
legally yeah yeah you got fighting take
it away kj let's get to the goddamn
questions here all right this one uh
home run never thought about i mean
we've been doing this a long [ __ ]
time right a long time this one's never
crossed our radar on a 172 episodes
we've done or whatever this is from mike
on the patreon do you share a driveway
with another house
[Laughter]
talk about a grand slam
i might have brought that up a while ago
i'd i'd never heard that because my
brother used to have that
and his family didn't have that no no
you don't have driveways or trailers
[Applause]
i don't i don't remember that
my brother at his old house had a
connecting there was because it was up a
hill remember you dropped me off at that
house there's a real steep hill his
driveway okay and the neighbor before he
moved there the neighbors had connected
it so you could like loop kind of okay
uh but that became a big thing and he
got in a big fight with his neighbors
over that what will they drive that's a
question of itself
did you fight with neighbors oh of
course yeah are you currently in a beef
with a neighbor oh yeah yeah we've
talked about it or an imaginary deer
have you ever gonna hoof to
hope broke up in third grade i cover
myself in piss
near me
no don't they come near you they're
attracted to it i think i think it's got
to be deer pissed
because they can't be anybody's piss
well if we need some we know who to go
[Laughter]
one stop shop explain this driveway
situation to me no i don't remember this
what do you mean they had a connector so
like what are you talking his driveway
in his neighbor's driveway instead of
both being on like the right side of the
house next to each other and they were
both really steep okay so his neighbor
at one point i guess before he moved in
there they the two people lived there
for like 20 years or whatever uh-huh and
the guy's wife couldn't back down the
driveway i guess because it was so so
she would pull it off she would loop she
would pull into her driveway then there
was like a connector and she would loop
down my brother up top up top and she
would loop around
so she could face so she could drive
straight down but my brother's driveway
and he didn't like that no he was fine
with it but then he would
sometimes they would block it because
they had two or three cars okay and then
he came out as a the neighbor came out
and yelled at my brother's wife i
believe for using cars in his own
driveway yeah being like you can't park
here because my wife can't get down and
that was tell you what
yeah my brother was like hey listen if
you can get through by all means please
use it so but i'm not
i'm not having we're not changing where
we park so you can yeah yeah yeah take
her to a [ __ ] parking lot teach her
how to back up yeah
what i mean
female drivers no survivors huh man you
flipped the switcher
[ __ ] ian soprano relaxing
let me tell you something you talk about
my boy venetia shit's gonna happen huh
uh hmm
yeah that's uh
that's why i think when we were when i
was born we lived in the northeast and
that was a shared driveway there was
like
two they were downhill into the house
because the house yeah did you ever have
a driveway separated by a fence
like right next to the driver what was
your driveway looking like
a chain link fence in the front yard is
a tough unlock yeah the toughest yes
your house has a chain-link fence around
it it's a real jailhouse
there better be a cemetery on this
especially if you don't
right that's what's important
if you don't keep the grass clean if you
got grass coming up the chain-link fence
oh god what did you have growing up
driveway regular driveway and then
12-foot wall in a guard tower
they're playing hammer again and they
chad venicio
deer down deer down
we had uh we had a regular driveway
neighbor uh had a driveway next to us
and there was a long patch of grass and
there was a like an apple
tree in between it oh that really would
you pick the apples yeah
it was nice yeah i had a really good job
it did it'd be great if none of this was
true
for sure is it
it's just a mouse on a wheel if you zoom
into his head i grew up in a home
[Laughter]
on the street since age of four
we had an apple tree
dirt of delaware
oh yeah thank you joe dirk great movie
great guy i grew up in silvertown yeah i
had a meteorite as a friend they
probably tried to leave you at that
campground they just couldn't get away
fast enough quickies making the rocks
let's go
i used to go rock picking
do you have a rock tumbler
i had one of those
it's real bad i think we might have
talked about it we have yeah what is
that you like try to polish your own
stones or say it was it was yeah i get
my stones balanced
okay
you saw it as a business opportunity you
were looking to get into the jewelry
business
that's a kj movie that's a kj well kj
with a fat head in one of those little
eye things
i was already bald moving fine stones
and antwerp i'm wearing i'm wearing a
bad blazer
trying to push diamonds on the other
kids you're appraising your mom's
wedding ring yeah
i'll give you 25 minutes yeah
[Applause]
ah fake ice a stone tumbler what a rock
tumbler so you would put like a beat up
[ __ ] nerd [ __ ] yeah it's an urge
that's why i don't know i wasn't a
[ __ ] nerd what are you talking about
apple trees cool as hell
[Laughter]
did you say you were trying to talk to
dear like three days ago why tell played
a recorder that's not the coolest scene
you've painted yeah you had a speech
impediment that stopped you from naming
your dog after a ghostbusters character
yeah
yeah a fun story
yeah i wouldn't label it as cool
you think you're a cool guy now do you
think you've always been a cool guy when
i think you got cool well i think that
when dave sure will be for the first
time zip it buttons
buttons
buttons is all right we got two new
nicknames kj and buttons
me next
there's not enough viagra in the world
i'd have to boof it
holy [ __ ] i think cool is uh
doing whatever you want not caring what
other people think that's the worst
would say yeah
that's what a nerd would say
i don't need other people to think about
a [ __ ] pacsun shirt
it's polaroid you probably go to the
pacific side no i got it all stacked
from zoomies
no off sacks for that avedo really
classy shop at sacks the packs on what a
hit but it was too wordy i appreciated
it though all right i didn't laugh at it
but at the time i was like it's cute all
right just letting you know take it easy
professor
is that it professor no
no no no professor buttons and kj
[Laughter]
it's pretty good
that sounds like a detective agency run
by cats
that's not a bad idea it sounds like
we're up for adoption
you can't split them up if you come down
to union square today you can have
buttons to professor and kj
you guys sound like imaginary friends i
grown up
phoenicia we start a band
the fighting we should ban fully from
talking
nothing
nothing nothing
[Laughter]
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
sprinkles
it was just such a quick rip on the
nothing
you pulled the parachute stepping out of
the plane
halfway out
shoots hit the helicopter blades
[Laughter]
ah i did something that was pretty
trashy you made me think of it a couple
nights ago i went down for a burny at
the house
i had a bottle of water with me and i
put the bottle of water down then went
back upstairs maybe like two hours later
i came back out and the water bottle was
still there and i drank out of it oh
whoa never what i did it was open too no
what i was thinking you left it closed
you come back open no i mean i left it
open oh
i will say though no way i will say i
leave my water in my water holder on my
bike
really
yeah leave my water bottle on my bike
that's all bonko's too come back
foley you got any water on you
yeah i do
what are you working with over there bud
club soda oh just a tiny little normal
sized club soda
are you talking about the [ __ ] big
boy
why is that what you want what
what why didn't you get the big one
it's like when andre the giant holds a
beer
does that have times when you're
supposed to drink yes
like when you're relearning how to shop
with a head injury
shop
yeah when they're like okay you're at
the grocery store and you spend a dollar
fifty on sugar
and then you need to get an apple
you got a lot of balls buddy
yeah i do they're [ __ ] nice and bad
you could be so lucky
he turns quick i know he
turns into a bad italian character
um yeah i think they're they're putting
the screws to me i got a [ __ ]
i got to do a gown i'm doing a gallon of
water a day for for the next week to get
really hydrated two gallons of mountain
dew
we gotta dilute the dew
i gotta cut this water somehow
[Laughter]
two parts do one part water the boss
kj's all over my [ __ ] it's the lord's
fentanyl
wait let me see that [ __ ] bottle
people have to wait i don't think we
have flood insurance yet
i gotta make sure that the the premium
space holy carries around a [ __ ]
firearm wherever he goes
that come with a dalmatian
does that come with straps put on your
back
yeah it tells you when you do it every
two hours put a goldfish in there
good morning hydrate yourself remember
your what
remember your goals remember your goal
chugging you're not fat you're big
hey ditch this and get a burger will you
at 3 pm it starts talking
don't do this you'll die soon
who are you kidding
2 o'clock
come on you know you want one
that's funny
oh [ __ ] very very funny all right let's
run through a couple of more here this
one
sir
haven't had the professor haven't had
one read yet
uh at any point did you ever have a belt
clip for your flip phone
yeah i used to work construction
oh yeah you said you used to come around
to the open mics i think with that would
that make sense remember that
what his his weird construction yeah
career
how long was that what did you do i just
remember he had a tool belt in the trunk
in the village people
yeah
i could show them to parties
i remember seeing that for the first
time you had a legit really yeah oh yeah
i used to keep all my tools in my trunk
yeah but it was weird it was like a it
was like a shitty honda accord or
something like that a camera yeah yeah
shitty honda of course
god bless where were you working
construction you were doing like
handyman stuff back in delaware yeah
could you imagine him coming in the room
i tore out and put up all drywalls in
your bathroom barley's old house i drive
all this this whole ceiling in this
house really in his bedroom would you
charge him for it
pretty
nice i told him to run it through
homeowners yeah yeah i used imaginary
drywall too vinaigio handles my
handles he counts he's my estimator
that's about two million in here
you're gonna have to take it up with the
deer
hey listen
it's 14 million and two salt licks do
you got that on you
my partner here loves apples if you got
them
i'll need a deposit of three carrots
and three ounces of deer urine
oh my god you are a bizzo
get me some antlers he can rub him up i
know any female deer
hasn't been laid in the water
he is there with the ian's there with
the two [ __ ] antlers
uh i never got it out never mind oh hey
fire kj cut that out will you debunk hey
buttons
with a b-side huh
hey i was working on some new stuff you
know what i mean it's a pretty show
you want the high heat you buy the
patreon
that's like the weekends
[Laughter]
treat that like a corporate gig you know
oh
[ __ ] oh god
uh this one i would probably assume this
is when chris ever ordered the chili as
the chili at wendy's
absolute [ __ ] lutely yeah the baked
potato on wendy's your goddamn [ __ ]
you're the fish fillet or in easter or
wendy's you're goddamn right forget
about easter all the time
those baked potatoes your mother's brush
from the sauce
okay i'm pretty sure that's her dick but
you don't talk about that it's almost
like you've never seen in a town no i i
can't you're like an alien trying to do
an italian i don't know if he's trying i
don't know if he's doing it bad to be
funny or if it's he's
yeah i'm being serious when i act
italian no i know you're not okay here
do a couple lines serious scene if you
had to play in like an italian mobster
in a movie
do it serious though give me a line
um
you gotta improvise it we're gonna okay
you ready we're gonna read the factory
tomorrow night around nine get some guys
together that's the line
next
someone with more hair please
tomorrow night around nine we're in the
[ __ ] factory you win we gotta get
some guys
you you butts the nash these pretzels
are making me thirsty i love doing the
many saints in newark
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's my nickname dame oh there you go
now we all got one we got kj we got the
dame the professor and buttons
that's it
gang we love you we'll see you next week
peace